can choose what what is music yeah
hunting with music watch what do that
you eat it while you listen to music
musica is music that's with melodies and
that kind of thing but Han cheese I have
no idea the town of hidden back is some
60 kilometers north of Frankfurt and
it's home to three factories that make
hand cheese or hunt kaiza in German one
of them is back in stock the cheese is
made by combining sour milk baking soda
and salt it's shaped into little patties
then placed in the sweating room where
it's matured at temperatures of around
25 degrees Celsius ah here's a hot feel
I by kaiser has a lot of protein little
fat and not much salt so it's very
healthy yeah this one hand kaisa is made
in several varieties and under different
names there's a kind with caraway seeds
made with paprika it's called Bowen
Congo and it's exported to Austria under
that name
ship to english-speaking countries it's
called German hand cheese pie mix what
isms order the export business stems
from the fact that immigrants who went
from Germany or Europe to Australia the
United States or Canada like to have
products from home they remember the
good old hand cheese and they want to
try it en la propiedad haunt casa has
been made in hidden bag for some 200
years the sour milk cheese was
originally a byproduct of milk
production farmers pressed it through
wooden suits to dry it there is an
exhibit on the process at the town's
local history museum
yeah nama hunky it's called hand cheese
because it was shaped by hand theater
people use the cheese press you put the
bowl of cheese here and then shape the
little hand cheeses like this so the
hunt case in he gashed and uma decent
people would then take their uniformly
sized cheese's to market of the American
such as the market in Frankfurt where
honkies Amit musique our hand cheese
with music is still a popular dish
tourist guide McHale host phone shows
visitors local specialties at this
market hall we have never tried con
kaiser MIT music the hand cheese has
served in a marinade the music it
comprises chopped onions in oil and
vinegar Pakal horstmann knows why this
marinade is called music music isn't
resting with vinegar oil and onions and
it said that this onions make music in
your body so now that that's clear how
does it taste
and I like the onions also honkies emit
music is a regular item on menus of many
Frankfurt restaurants including some
lemon was it fizzy new music is the name
of a marinade made of raspberry vinegar
onions radishes and beet juice both
variations are served with bread and
butter and caraway seeds but no forks
allowed this tablet swagman can probably
be explained by the fact that this was a
dish for poor people and the fork was
still a luxury at the end of the 19th
century legal used bread instead of
forks and that's still the tradition
with hunt Kaiser then as now the classic
accompaniment is a glass of apple wine
the traditional drink from Frankfurt